FEMALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, Al Pittampalli.
[APPLAUSE]
AL PITTAMPALLI: So the
date is March 14, 2011.
President Obama
and his war cabinet
are meeting at the
White House to discuss
how to attack the Pakistani
compound allegedly
housing Osama bin Laden.
Now at first the
discussion is all
about coming in from the air.
They're talking about
firing a small missile
from an unmanned
drone or dropping
a large bomb from a B-2.
But there were a
few problems, right?
The first problem is, if
you fire a small missile
you might miss.
If you drop a
large bomb, there'd
be a high risk of
civilian casualties.
And in either case hard
to really determine
whether you got the guy.
That's when the administration
for the very first time
began to discuss the possibility
of a Special Operations ground
raid.
But in many ways, this was
the riskiest strategy of all.
What if the raid team was
detected while helicoptering
into the Pakistani airspace?
What if the Pakistani
military, which
was stationed dangerously
close to the compound,
engaged the raid
team in a firefight?
What if US troops were
injured or killed?
These were frightening
questions that required answers.
So in order to answer
those questions,
the president and his
team consulted the man
who'd ultimately be tapped
to lead the mission, a man
by the name of Admiral
William McRaven.
Admiral William McRaven is
the commander of Joint Special
Operations Command.
He's one of the most successful
military leaders in the history
of United States military.
And he certainly looks the part.
The guy's 6 foot 1, he's
got impeccable posture,
this domineering presence,
four-star general.
But there was one thing
about the guy that
was unusual to the
administration, something that
was atypical of military brass.
McRaven was humble.
He was modest.
He was open to
suggestion and unusually
willing to change his mind.
So from the very
beginning McRaven
admitted he didn't
have all the answers.
In fact, when he first presented
his plan to the president,
he said, Mr. President,
we haven't thoroughly
tested this out yet.
And we don't know
if we could do it,
but when I do I'll
tell you straight up.
McRaven ultimately
did test the plan.
It became successful.
But still, he reminded everyone
of its fallibility, how things
could go wrong at any moment.
Now over the course
of many meetings,
the president and his
team grilled McRaven,
questioning his plan,
second-guessing his thinking.
But McRaven didn't seem to mind.
He approached the
scrutiny without ego.
In fact, in response to a
good question, he would say,
you know what?
I haven't thought about
that, but I need to.
And he wasn't just
paying lip service.
He was making
substantial changes
to his plans based on
the feedback of others.
So for example,
McRaven originally
proposed having backup
Chinook helicopters stationed
on the Afghan-Pakistani border.
That way they would
prevent any infringement
on Pakistani sovereignty.
But the president disagreed.
He wanted those helicopters
as close to the compound as
possible in case the SEAL team
needed to get the hell out
of there.
McRaven was persuaded.
The helicopters would be
flown deep into Pakistan
near the Abbottabad
compound ready to move.
On April 29, 2011,
President Obama,
after a careful deliberation
process with his team,
officially ordered the
SEAL Team 6 raid overseen
by Admiral William McRaven.
Why?
Why did he do it?
Later he would explain it was
his confidence in McRaven that
led him to go ahead
with the raid.
He said, the guy just never
seemed surprised by anything.
Remember that quote because
it turned out to be true.
During the raid, one of the
SEALs' Black Hawk helicopters
went down.
The administration
began to panic.
They were watching via secure
link from the White House.
Some people didn't know
what to expect next.
One person actually
thought he might throw up.
But not McRaven.
McRaven was calm.
He was expressionless.
Later, afterwards he
described it, he said,
we had a contingency plan.
We executed that
contingency plan.
And we continued on
with the mission.
And continue on
they did, completing
one of the most successful
military operations in United
States history.
Ladies and gentlemen, my
name is Al Pittampalli.
I'm the author of a book
called "Persuadable."
And today, what I
want to talk to you
about is what I
believe to be the most
critical skill of
modern leadership,
something I call persuadability.
Now persuadability,
or being persuadable,
is the genuine willingness
to change your mind
in the face of evidence.
It means rejecting
absolute certainty.
It means treating your beliefs
as temporary and acknowledging,
no matter how confident you are
about any particular belief,
you could be wrong.
Now this might be a
little bit strange
to think about in the context
of a leadership skill, right?
If anything, we admire
heroes and leaders
that do the opposite,
that resist persuasion.
I mean, just look
at the language
of successful leadership.
Strong leaders stay the course.
They defy the odds.
They prove their critics wrong.
They stand firm in
their convictions.
And then what do
we call leaders who
actually do change their mind?
We're quick to label them
flip-floppers and pushovers.
We think of them as weak.
In fact, our culture
indoctrinates
us to believe this
to be true, right?
I call this the traditional
leadership archetype.
It's embodied by the three
C's, conviction, confidence,
and consistency.
That's what we believe
strong leaders to be.
That's what I believe
But for the last
four years, I've
been studying the most
successful leaders in history
and modern leaders, at least.
And what I found
is, one by one, they
are bucking the traditional
leadership archetype
in favor of a new
way of thinking,
a new way of leading, what
I call persuadability.
And the question is why?
Why is it that these
leaders are sacrificing
the cost of being perceived as
a weak leader to be persuadable?
And the reality is
because they notice,
they know something
that other people don't.
Being persuadable is
the ultimate advantage.
So to understand why
and understand how,
let's revisit McRaven's raid
on the Abbottabad compound.
So there's one thing
you have to understand
about the Pakistani raid is
it was a Special Operations
mission.
And Special
Operations is special.
It's unconventional
and full of surprises.
Information is coming in
up until the last minute
before the mission commences.
And when that occurs, in
that kind of environment,
being decisive-- this
traditional leadership
archetype of the three
C's-- doesn't work so well.
Maybe it works when the
environment is simple, right?
When the world is static.
But McRaven understood something
that most people don't really
embrace often, which is
that, in a world that
is more complex, more
turbulent, more fast
changing than ever, the answer
is to be able to be prepared
to change your mind.
That's the only way to succeed.
In fact, that's the way to
be unsurprisable, right?
To be the guy that's never
surprised by anything,
you have to admit you
don't have all the answers.
And you have to be willing
to change your mind.
But being willing
to change your mind
isn't just a lesson for a few
elite units in the military.
It's happening everywhere.
The world is changing.
Globalization,
hyperconnectedness,
the rise of the
internet are all making
the world complex, turbulent,
and entirely uncertain.
So whether it be
business, politics,
medicine, philanthropy, being
persuadable, the willingness
to change your mind, is
an advantage everywhere
because right now everything
is special operations.
So agility, the ability to
adapt to changing circumstances,
is an advantage of
being persuadable.
But it's not the only
advantage of being persuadable.
There are actually
two more, and I'd
like to take you
through those right now.
And then what I'd
like to do is actually
talk to you about how
to be persuadable.
So let's talk about the second
advantage of being persuadable.
In 2007, a man by
the name of Ray Dalio
traveled to the White House
with an ominous warning.
The economy was headed
towards catastrophe.
This wasn't going to be
some just regular downturn.
This was going to be a
deep global recession.
Now the senior economic staffers
of the Bush administration
ignored Dalio that day.
That would turn out
to be a huge mistake
because a year later the
economy went into free fall.
The government was blindsided.
Ray's competitors were
losing their shirts.
But Ray was making a fortune.
See, Ray was prepared.
He had programmed into
his trading system
some early warning
indicators that
would tell him when
he needed to pull out
of certain affected investments.
One day one of his
indicators told
him to pull out of several
banks, including Bear Stearns.
A week later, Bear
Stearns collapsed.
This, ladies and
gentlemen, is Ray Dalio.
Ray Dalio is one of the most
successful hedge fund investors
in the world.
Inarguably he runs
the biggest hedge fund
in the world, Bridgewater.
Some people call him the
da Vinci of investing.
And John Cassidy
from "The New Yorker"
says he's got an uncanny ability
to anticipate economic trends.
His competitors are all
tearing their shirts out,
or tearing their
hair out, rather,
trying to figure out, how does
he know what's going to happen?
What does he know that we don't?
And that is the wrong question
because he doesn't know.
Right?
He's not Biff Tannen from
"Back to the Future II."
He doesn't have an almanac that
tells him what trades to make.
No.
The secret to Ray Dalio's
success, his accuracy,
isn't at all what he knows.
It's how he thinks.
So in order to
explain what I mean,
I've got to talk to you about
this guy, Philip Tetlock.
Philip Tetlock is a professor at
the University of Pennsylvania.
He's an academic juggernaut.
He's responsible
for what I think
is one of the most important
studies over the last 30 years.
So Philip Tetlock
about 30 years ago
was really frustrated because he
wanted to answer this question.
Do experts really know
what they're talking about?
I mean, how many times
do you see experts
on TV that are pontificating
about what's going
to happen in the future, right?
Do they really know what
they're talking about?
We never get to know because,
by the time judgment day comes,
there's no reckoning
because we've
all lost track of
the predictions,
and therefore there's
no accountability.
Well, Tetlock wanted
to change that.
Tetlock decided to
study meticulously,
to track meticulously
lots of experts.
We're talking about 284
experts in total, upwards
of 82,000 predictions,
to find out,
do these experts really know
what they're talking about?
After two decades, what he
found made huge headlines
and was pretty depressing.
Experts performed
abysmally on the whole.
In general, they didn't
perform much better
than your average
Joe on the street.
But there was a silver lining.
There was a subset of
experts in Tetlock's study
that actually performed
significantly better
than everyone else.
And what he found
was that it had
much less to do
with what they know
and more to do with
how they think.
So he classified these
successful forecasters
and unsuccessful forecasters
into two kinds of groups.
He called them
foxes and hedgehogs.
So hedgehogs know
one big thing, OK?
So these guys had these
grand, simple understandings
of the world.
And they were so confident
in these theories
that, when information
would come up
or an event would
occur that contradicted
their theory, instead of
throwing out the information--
or instead of throwing
out the theory,
they would throw
out the information.
Foxes, on the other hand, had a
different way of doing things,
right?
They had theories too, but
they were much more skeptical
of these theories.
And therefore, when
information would come up
or an event would occur that
contradicted their theories,
they would just
change their theory.
And they would do it over
and over and over again.
In short, in a word,
foxes were persuadable.
And now we know the
secret of Ray Dalio.
He's a fox.
And he spends most of
his day trying to avoid
being a hedgehog, right?
In fact, 30 years
ago, he decided
to start tracking all of his
trades, all of his predictions,
right?
So he took out a notebook
and he would write down
the trades he was making,
and then he would follow up.
He would track
them and watch them
to make sure that those trades
came true or were successful.
If they weren't, he would
assume there was something
about his understanding of
the world that was wrong,
so he would just change it.
Dalio's been doing
this for 30 years,
and he takes no shame in this
constant process of revision.
Now from the outside this makes
him look really inconsistent,
right?
He's constantly
contradicting himself.
In fact, some might
call him a flip-flopper.
But who cares?
He doesn't because the reward
is deadly accuracy, one
that makes him one of the
most accurate investors
in the world.
Let's go to growth now,
the third advantage
of being persuadable.
In 1974, a guy by the name of
Alan Ricks, who's a researcher,
was following up on
a long-term study
of kids who were highly
disturbed as young boys.
He wanted to find out-- all
these kids had undergone
psychiatric treatment,
psychotherapy, as kids,
and he was following
up with them
to see how they were
performing as adults.
What he found was
that most of the kids
weren't doing very well
as adults, unfortunately.
But there were a few
kids that were actually
doing extremely well.
And what was
remarkable to him was,
when he dug a little
deeper, is that those kids,
the ones that were
doing well, were all
treated by the same provider.
Ricks came to the conclusion
that, in the field
of psychotherapy, there
are a few therapists that
are performing
exceptionally well,
that are getting results
head and shoulders
above their peers.
He called these high-performing
therapists supershrinks.
Now at the time, the
field was way more
interested in finding
out what makes
for good therapy
versus good therapist.
And so Ricks's conclusion
didn't get much attention.
That was until a team of
researchers in the 2000s
found his study, and they
were fascinated by it.
They wanted to find out what
made supershrinks so super.
This is the lead
on the team, a guy
by the name of Scott Miller.
What these guys had,
the International Center
for Clinical Excellence,
at their disposal
was lots of data.
So they had a lot of
data on patient outcomes
and therapists.
And what they would
do is they would
come up with a
list of attributes,
like, everything you
could think of that
might separate the
good therapists
from the great therapists.
We're talking about age,
experience, level of education,
gender, the mode of therapy,
all of these things.
And one by one they would
cross check these attributes
with the data.
But one after one they
kept striking out.
They couldn't
determine what actually
made the supershrinks so super,
and so actually after some time
they decided to give up.
Until two years later,
Scott Miller was on a plane.
He was on a flight, and he
saw this "Fortune" magazine
article.
And he picked it up, and
he started reading it.
And it was by a guy,
the article was by a guy
named K. Anders Ericsson.
Now many of you might be
familiar with that name
because he's the father of
a concept called deliberate
practice.
So Anders Ericsson's
claim to fame
is that he studied
experts in a wide variety
of cognitively complex skills.
We're talking about from
violin, to chess players,
to lots of different
kinds of skills.
And what he found was that
the quantity of practice
didn't determine whether or not
these people became masters.
It was important, right?
It just wasn't sufficient.
He actually famously
came up with this idea
of the 10,000-hours rule.
So it was important.
But what was much more important
was the quality of practice,
right?
Experts and masters don't
just perform the same thing
over and over and over again.
It's not just rote repetition.
No, they're constantly concerned
with negative feedback.
See, what they
want to do is they
want to understand what are the
weaknesses in their performance
so they can continually
adjust and improve.
And they do so obsessively.
This was the revelation
that Scott Miller needed.
Armed with this fresh new
perspective, he and his team
dove back into
the data, and they
found something really
interesting in their data
that they hadn't seen
the first time around.
In fact, they couldn't
believe that they missed it.
It turns out when they looked
at the lowest performing
therapists, the lowest
performing therapists,
they found something
very confounding.
When you looked at their
own self-evaluations,
it turns out the lowest
performing therapists actually
thought they were the best
performing therapists.
They were delusional.
They were suffering
from what psychologists
call illusory superiority.
Don't laugh too hard
because we all suffer
from illusory superiority.
Every single person
here thinks they're
more attractive, more
intelligent, more honest
than they probably actually are.
And the research has lots of
examples of how this works,
right?
Now here's the problem
with illusory superiority.
If K. Anders Ericsson is right,
it does protect our ego, right?
It prevents us from having a
nervous breakdown every now
and then.
But the cost is, it
prevents us from engaging
in deliberate practice.
Because in order to engage
in deliberate practice,
we need to understand
our weaknesses,
and illusory
superiority makes us not
understand our weaknesses.
But there is one
fascinating conclusion
from the research, which
is that, even though we're
really bad at understanding
our own weaknesses,
it turns out we're actually
really good at pointing out
somebody else's weaknesses.
And so the solution is actually
really simple for masters,
for people who really want to
improve at an accelerated rate.
You should allow other people
to point out your weaknesses
for you.
And this, it turns out, was
the secret of supershrinks.
Supershrinks were
obsessive about asking
for negative feedback.
I mean, there's lots of ways to
get negative feedback, right?
You can try to do
it yourself and you
can intuit it, which a lot of
supershrinks, it turns out,
did do.
But the main way that
they got their feedback
was by asking their clients.
Now this is kind
of unprecedented
in the therapeutic
relationship, right?
The therapist is
usually the one that's
giving the feedback
to the client.
And here they are asking, right?
They would ask questions
like, how am I doing?
How empathetic was I
at today's session?
Did we talk about what you
wanted to talk about today?
And they didn't just stop
at those questions, right?
Like, they kept following
up because people don't like
to give you negative feedback.
So they would continue to ask
over and over and over again.
And they were
persistent because they
wanted to make sure they
got that negative feedback.
And that, it turns
out, is how they
grew at an accelerated rate.
And they didn't just
ask for the feedback.
They acted upon it.
They were persuadable.
They actually embraced it.
They didn't see it as a
favor to the other person.
They saw it as a gift.
Because as Cornell
psychologist David Dunning
writes, who is one of
the foremost researchers
on illusory superiority,
the road to self-insight
runs through other people.
So now that we've talked
about the advantages of being
persuadable, I want
to talk a little bit
about how to be persuadable.
Because it's not
that easy, right?
Every single person here who
buys into this argument--
maybe you don't-- but if you
do, that being persuadable is
an advantage, that's not enough.
Because it turns
out there's lots
of obstacles that prevent
you from being persuadable
even if you want to be.
And we're going to talk
about them right now.
In fact, it's almost like
a quest you have to go on.
It's almost like a
journey you have to fight.
This is our heroine,
our persuadable leader
who wants to be persuadable.
What we're going
to find is she is
going to experience
lots of obstacles
along the way that are
going to prevent her
from being persuadable.
The first is this thing
called the feeling of knowing.
So here's what I want
you to do right now.
I want you to think
about something,
everybody here,
think about something
you're extremely certain about.
Something that you're
100% confident about,
100% sure about.
Maybe it's a political belief.
Maybe it's your belief that
either looser or stricter gun
regulation would lead to a
better society or less crime.
Maybe it's a project
or a business idea
you have in the
back of your mind
that you're just sure is
going to change the world.
Or maybe it's an argument you're
in with your spouse right now
about how to best
discipline your kids,
and you just know you're
right and they're wrong.
OK?
Really think about
this for a moment.
Now that feeling that you're
experiencing right now
is what the neurophilosopher
Dr. Robert Burton calls
a feeling of knowing, OK?
It's a sensation that gives
us this feeling of certainty.
Now here's the problem.
We want to believe
that that feeling is
the result of some kind
of rational analysis,
some good reasons we
have to feel that way.
And it's not, OK?
The feeling of
knowing arises out
of involuntary mechanisms in
the brain independent of reason,
independent of
rational analysis.
But it sure doesn't
feel like that, right?
It feels totally reliable.
It feels like the truth.
But the truth is
that it's unreliable.
It doesn't always tell
us what's accurate.
And so here's the problem.
The feeling of knowing is
completely involuntary, right?
We don't choose it.
You didn't choose to have that
feeling any more than we choose
to fall in love or get angry.
These emotions
actually happen to us.
So we can't just get rid of
the feeling of knowing, right?
It stands in the way of us
being persuadable, right?
Because the first
thing we need to do
to be persuadable is to accept
the possibility that we're
wrong, right?
But there is a bright side.
There is something that
we can and must do.
Because we can't get
rid of a feeling,
but we can learn to distrust it.
And in order to
do that, we should
recall a moment of opacity.
So here's what a moment
of opacity is, right?
Everyone knows what a
moment of clarity is.
We've all heard that before.
It's like an experience
you had in your life
where just something was
so right that you just
felt like you understood
the world, right?
It was like for the
first time ever,
you could see the universe
just completely unobstructed.
A moment of opacity
is the opposite.
It's a time in
your life where you
were so sure you were going
to get something right
and you got it wrong.
Everybody who predicted that
Donald Trump wouldn't make it
to a primary, much less
win three in a row,
should have had a
moment of opacity.
This painful realization
that, wow, we
don't understand the world
as much as we think we do.
The problem is,
whenever we experience
this moment of opacity, five
seconds later we forget, right?
We learn to distrust
that feeling of knowing
in that moment because
we realized it was wrong,
and then five seconds later or
five minutes later we forget.
Persuadable leaders make
sure they never forget.
Your moment of opacity,
as painful as it is,
is your greatest
asset because it
will remind you to distrust
your feeling of knowing.
Our second villain on the
path to being persuadable
is the confirmation bias.
So we all know what the
confirmation bias is.
It's the force
that has us believe
what we want to believe, right?
It gives us information
and it causes
us to seek out information that
confirms what we already know.
We've all been led by
the confirmation bias.
Just think about
the last time you've
seen an article on Facebook.
And you see an
article headline that
just seems infuriating to
you, just from the headline.
So you click on it and you
race through the article
as fast as you can, basically
dismissing every single point,
you know, calling the
thing biased propaganda
and then deleting it or getting
it out of your Facebook feed
or, if you're like me,
unfriending the person who
posted it, right?
This is what we do.
This is the protocol.
Now compare that to what we do
when we see an article that we
initially like, right?
So it's an article
with a headline, oh,
that seems interesting.
I kind of like this.
You go through it, it takes
you two seconds, you read it,
you love it, and then you
share it with all your friends.
And then you celebrate.
This asymmetry leads
us away from the truth.
It leads us to things that we
already know, which is great,
at least for our ego.
But it's terrible when
we're seeking the truth.
So how do we combat
this confirmation bias,
which is often insidious?
We often don't even know
when it's taken hold of us.
The answer is to
argue with others.
So there's this amazing
thing that happens.
Arguing is actually
a beautiful thing.
It actually produces, often, the
most reliable results, right?
It's the quickest
path to the truth.
Think about the one
area in our society
where we desperately
want the truth.
In our justice system, right?
I mean, we desperately don't
want an innocent person
to go to jail for the
rest of their lives
for a crime they didn't commit.
So what do we do?
We don't commission a team to go
on a fact-finding investigation
and render a verdict alone.
No.
We know that the confirmation
bias would probably
lead them astray.
So smartly, what we do is we
have an adversarial system.
We have a defense, and
we have a prosecution.
We have them argue
against each other
because there's this
amazing thing that happens.
The confirmation bias
alone is a weakness, right?
It leads us away from the truth.
But when you have two
confirmation biases that
are directed at each other,
that are opposing each other,
it actually balances
each other out.
And so when you
argue with people
that disagree with you-- not
with people who agree with you,
that can actually
result in polarization
and get you further
from the truth.
But when you argue with
people that you disagree with,
it actually gets you
closer to the truth,
and that's the best form
of being persuadable.
But there is a problem
because that's not
how most people argue, is it?
If you've ever seen an argument,
it's more like a quarrel,
right?
It's like two people
who are trying
to tear each other apart.
Just look at the
political debates
if you want evidence of that.
So the question is, why is that?
So the metaphor I use for how
we argue is skeet shooting.
So you're arguing
with somebody else
and somebody makes a good point.
It's almost like a clay
target that's flung in the air
that you take your shotgun
with and you shoot it down.
And then when they make
another point, you turn the gun
and you shoot it down.
And you obsessively try to
shoot down all the points.
And if you can do
that, then you win.
That is a terrible way
to argue, it turns out.
It's a great way if you
want to argue to win.
It's a terrible way if you
want to argue to improve
the accuracy of your beliefs.
So why is it?
Why do we do that?
Well, the answer,
one of the reasons
is because of a force
called dichotomous thinking.
So human beings
don't like ambiguity.
We like to believe the
world is black and white,
wrong or right, 100%
certain or 0% certain.
We want to believe that LeBron
James is the best basketball
player in the world or he's not.
We want to believe that
intervening in Syria will
produce good outcomes and less
conflict in the Middle East
or it won't.
And so what the logic goes
when you see the world that way
is that, if somebody can
score a point on you,
if somebody can prove that
one little thing that part
of your reasoning is wrong,
well, then that means
you must be totally wrong.
And so therefore, we have to
perfectly defend our positions.
But that's not how
the world works.
The world is not
black and white.
It's entirely uncertain.
It's shades of gray.
So what we have to do is we
have to make uncertain judgments
based on probabilities.
And so in order to battle
dichotomous thinking,
we need to think about
our beliefs incrementally.
We need to update
them incrementally.
So here's what you do.
Next time when you
argue with somebody
and you really want
to be persuadable,
imagine, instead of
putting your hand
on your shotgun the entire
time, keep your hand on a dial.
So imagine there's a
dial in front of you.
It's a radio dial.
And if you turn the dial all
the way to the left, that
means you're 100% certain in
any particular belief, decision,
opinion you have right now.
All the way to the right
means you're 100% certain.
All the way to the left
means you're 0% certain.
Now, when somebody makes
a good point, instead
of being concerned
with shooting it down,
all you have to be focused
on is just turning the dial.
If they make a point that
is good but contradicts
your opinion, just turn the
dial a little bit to the left.
If some evidence surfaces
that supports your position,
turn the dial a little
bit to the right.
If by the end of the argument
your dial is to the left
or to the right of where
it was when you began,
congratulations, you've
learned something.
You've improved the
accuracy of your beliefs.
But we can't just turn
that dial forever, right,
because at some point we
have to make a decision.
We have to take a stand.
We have to decide whether
to change our mind or not.
And that is when the most
insidious and most powerful
force prevents us from
changing our mind,
and that is attachment.
In our quest to be
persuadable, the problem
is we fall in love with
our beliefs, right?
We have what are
called favored beliefs,
which are beliefs
that we care about,
that we don't want to see go.
It's usually
because they're tied
into our identity, our
relationships, or our material
self-interest.
Upton Sinclair
has a great quote.
He said, "It's difficult to
make a man understand something
when his salary depends on
him not understanding it."
Which is exactly
the point, right?
We have a lot tied
into these beliefs
and we don't want
to see them go.
The people that may
experience this,
it's most salient for
people who experience this,
is writers, right?
So writers are a
pretty neurotic bunch.
We often fall in love
with our work, right?
So every sentence,
every paragraph
can feel like it's our own baby.
And so when an editor
points out to us
that maybe this
paragraph isn't the best,
maybe this chapter isn't the
best and maybe it should go,
we get infuriated, right,
because it feels like we're
abandoning our own offspring.
And so there is this
indispensable advice that's
given to writers
because we know,
any writer who's worth
their salt knows,
that editing is a critical
part of the process, right?
We need to get rid
of the bad ideas
so that we can get
the good ideas.
And so this indispensable
piece of advice
that you've probably heard
before is, kill your darlings.
Instead of letting your editor
passively and slowly drag
your darlings away from you
as tears are running down
your cheeks, you
should grab the knife
and take matters
into your own hands.
Now this sounds-- I mean, it's
a crass expression, right?
But for good reason because
it acknowledges the fact
that letting go of our favored
beliefs can feel painful,
can feel wrong, can feel
twisted, can feel even unholy.
But we have to do it
because the sooner we
can get rid of the bad
ideas, the sooner we
can have good ideas.
But that's not the only reason
we should kill our darlings
because so far what
I've talked about
is a persuadable advantage
for the individual, right?
The benefits of agility,
accuracy, and growth.
But there's a much more
important advantage
that we should all
be concerned with,
and that is the
collective advantage,
the advantage for society.
You need to kill your
darlings because that often
is the fastest path
to changing the world.
So we in this society have
this marketplace of ideas.
It's a beautiful thing.
The marketplace of ideas
through this exchange of ideas
actually makes it more likely
that the best ideas prevail.
The best policies, the best
opinions, the best beliefs
are the ones that
rise to the top.
And yet our
marketplace of ideas is
broken because in order to have
a marketplace, a functioning
marketplace, you need
buyers and sellers.
But in our marketplace, it's
like everybody's a seller,
right?
Everybody wants to
sell their idea,
but nobody is willing to buy.
And that's a problem.
When we think about all
the great social movements
and social change
in history, we think
about the persuaders, right?
We think about the great
Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr.,
Mahatma Gandhi,
Susan B. Anthony,
people who changed
hearts and minds,
these committed
activists, that was
what sparked and led to change.
And of course, those
people were fundamental,
they were instrumental,
they're heroes.
But that's not telling
the entire story
because, in order for change
to occur, in order for people
to sell change,
you need people who
are willing to buy it, right?
There were opponents,
there were people
on the other side
that needed to accept
and be persuaded in order
for that change to occur.
So that's my invitation
for you all today
is to become buyers, is to
really look into the world
and see, what are the ideas
that I can embrace that conflict
with my current ideas?
Where can I show up to
the table and actually
have a genuine willingness
to change my mind?
And to actually
accept the possibility
that maybe I'm wrong?
That's going to require a little
bit of a different mindset,
right?
I say that the mindset
that we usually have,
the mantra that's
going through our head
over and over again as we
interact with the world is,
let my idea prevail.
That's the mantra
of persuasiveness.
But I want to offer you
a different mantra today,
one that I think
is more valuable
and it takes a little
bit more courage,
but I think it's way more
advantageous for society
and the individual.
And that is, let the
best idea prevail.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So at this time, if
you have any questions,
there are microphones
in the aisles.
So please, you know, I'd love
to field any comments you have.
AUDIENCE: And so my
question is, how do you
ensure that you don't
overdo it so you come out
as being, like, not
have enough credit
or not confident enough about
your beliefs and positions,
whatever?
AL PITTAMPALLI: That's
a really great question.
So let's just first dispense
with an obvious straw
man, which is, being persuadable
does not mean gullible, right?
It doesn't mean
always persuaded.
So just because you come to the
table and you have this genuine
willingness to change your mind,
if people don't provide you
with good reasons or good
argument or a reason to change
your mind, then you shouldn't.
That being said, there's
also truth to this idea
that we can't be too
persuadable, right?
I mean, think about it this way.
You know, if you're a
leader and you're driving
and you're about
to head off a cliff
and there are other
people riding with you,
you don't have time to
be persuadable, right?
Everybody's going to have
their own opinion on what
you should do.
But as a leader
when time is short,
you need to just
steer the wheel.
So the opposite of
persuadable is decisive.
And so what leaders
need to do, I think,
is vacillate between being
persuadable and being decisive.
Now the problem is,
most people, when
they think about
leadership, always think
that we should be decisive.
And if we need to
be persuadable,
fine, but it's kind of not the
hallmark of a great leader.
So we'll kind of be
persuadable, but then we'll
hurry back over to
being decisive again.
At best that's how
leaders operate.
The argument of this
book is not that we
don't need to be decisive
often, because we do.
It's that, instead of
being a decisive leader who
has to be persuadable
every once in a while,
you should be a
persuadable leader who
sometimes needs to be decisive.
So we should live in
persuadability because,
especially when it comes
to the big things in life.
When it comes to
the small things,
be decisive because a good
enough decision is good enough.
You don't need accuracy,
agility, and growth.
But when it comes to
the big things, when
it comes to the
big decisions, when
it comes to important
ideas, we need
to be persuadable because
that's how we ensure
that we have the best outcomes.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so
one of the points
you mentioned for
being persuadable
is arguing with others.
Now I find that my peer groups,
people who I interact with,
they share a lot of
the same beliefs.
Now I'm wondering, when I go out
there and try to find someone
to argue with, am I
going out to the street
and finding a person with
opposite beliefs as me?
Or how do I find
the ideal person
to argue with where it's
a positive exchange?
AL PITTAMPALLI: That's
a great question.
So there's a journalist
named Bill Bishop who wrote
a book called "The Big Sort."
And his argument is that
our country, especially
our country, has kind of turned
into this environment where
we are surrounded by people
who share our beliefs, right?
It's called
homophily, I believe.
Wherein that, think about
where you live, right?
I mean, think about
New York City.
But even your local
neighborhoods in New York City.
Think about the
people around you.
The diversity of opinion
and political belief
is so narrow, right?
And so what we need to do,
what we need to make sure
we do is we need to get
outside of our bubble
as much as we can.
And there's lots of ways to
do this, but one of the ways
to do this is through media.
Think about the media that
you watch all the time.
There's liberal media and
there's conservative media.
And if you're liberal, you
probably watch liberal news.
If you're conservative,
you probably
watch conservative news.
And I mean, the
internet is so fractured
and fragmented
that we could just
find whatever is the station
or the book or the article
or the television show that fits
into our existing worldview.
And we need to fight that.
So what I challenge you to do
is, instead of finding books
that you already know
you're going to like,
that you're already going
to agree with, find books
that you think you're
going to disagree with,
that are completely different
from your worldview.
It always infuriates
me when people give me
a book as a recommendation.
They say, oh, I
got you this book.
I know you're going to like it.
No, give me a book that I'm
not going to like, right?
Because I always read
books that I like.
I want you to find the most
intelligent, strongest argument
that contradicts something
that I already believe.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I really
enjoyed your talk.
And sort of leading
on the last question.
I also agree with
your discussion
of the dangers of
the echo chamber
that we live in
politically and culturally.
So I'm wondering if you do see
any signs across the country
for venues in which
people are having
these kind of positive
debates and actual marketplace
of ideas.
The current political debates
do not do that at all.
And that's from within
the same parties.
So I wonder where
are the places where
people with strong
different opinions
can reliably come together?
Do you see any positive signs?
AL PITTAMPALLI: The
short answer is no.
I think there's a real lack
of leadership in that area.
I think the political
climate is so polarized
that, even if you try
to be that person,
if you try to be the person
that says, hey, wait a minute.
Let's make sure we're not
just gravitating to our ideas
or the conservative
idea, the liberal idea,
let's try to gravitate
towards the best idea, that is
such a controversial position.
So it's very tough
right now, which
is one of the reasons I
wrote this book because I
wanted to try to help shift
the culture in some small way.
That being said,
there's lots of havens
outside of the political
process, right?
So if you google right now.
For example, there's a
rationalist community.
There's people who
pride themselves,
they call them rationalists
because they pride themselves
on being rational and updating
their beliefs in the face
of evidence that are kind
of apolitical in the sense
that they don't care from what
party the idea comes from.
They just want the best idea.
And so you can always find those
kinds of like-minded people.
And I think that the best
thing that anybody can do
is to try to take
on your own tribe.
Because if outsiders decide to
be persuadable, that's great.
But if you want to
change the system,
you need insiders to do it.
So I actually dedicate
an entire chapter
to this concept of
taking on your own tribe.
You know, if you're an outsider
and you try to give a speech
or try to persuade
people on a-- like,
imagine-- think about the last
time a Republican has stood up
at the DNC convention
and said, hey, you guys
need to change the way you're
doing this, and that worked.
That never works.
But what happens when a Democrat
stands up on the DNC stage
and says, hey, we
need to rethink this?
That often doesn't work either,
but it has a better chance.
So my invitation
to people who want
to kind of change
the system is to find
ways to take on your own tribe.
We're kind of indoctrinated to
take on other people's tribe.
We're always saying, you guys
are wrong, our tribe is right.
But find ways.
One of the quickest
ways to change the world
and have an impact
is to find areas
where your own tribe is wrong.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, excellent talk.
So speaking on that subject,
I'm imagining the scenario when
you're working with your team.
And you're willing
to be persuadable,
but obviously other team
members are not necessarily.
Maybe there are some
bigger egos in the room.
So what are some
actionable words or phrases
that we could use in the
moment to convince somebody
in our team to be persuadable
other than saying something
like, well, what
if you're wrong?
AL PITTAMPALLI: OK.
That's a really great question.
So how do we persuade others
to be persuadable, right?
The answer to your
question is, it's
virtually impossible
in the moment
to convince somebody
to be persuadable.
Because when you say-- you're
in the middle of an argument
with somebody and they're
being stubborn and you say,
I want you to be persuadable,
what you're telling
them is that you're wrong.
And that's not being very
persuadable yourself, actually,
because that means you've kind
of foregone the possibility
that you might be wrong.
And so the only way
to actually convince
people to be persuadable is
before the kind of argument
happens, right?
Like, instead of kind of
advancing any kind of agenda,
you actually try to set up an
environment in which you all
agree to this certain
set of rules, right?
We're going to let
the best idea prevail.
So before the meeting
occurs, or before you
get into some kind of
conflict with somebody,
or before you start
to butt heads,
you have to try to
spread this idea
that the best way to get
this accuracy, agility,
and growth and the best
way to run an organization,
the best way to make decisions
is to make sure we are-- it's
an idea meritocracy, right?
We're not picking a
decision or an opinion
because the most powerful
person in the room says it.
We're doing it because
it's the best idea.
That's a very hard
thing to do, again,
and that's one of the
reasons why I wrote a book.
So I would say, best answer,
give them a copy of my book.
Second best answer, do
your best to explain it,
but not in the middle
of a heated conflict.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
I was wondering if
you could expand
on what you think or looked
at to be the factors that
have contributed to
maybe what we see
as an increase in
those number of leaders
who are being more vulnerable?
And I'm particularly
wondering whether you
looked at how gender
or the leaders'
attitudes toward diversity
or, to your earlier
point, the amount of
diversity surrounding them
either helped or hindered their
ability to be persuadable.
AL PITTAMPALLI: Yeah, so I think
that the rapid pace of change
is really what has allowed
these leaders to actually
be more persuadable
more recently, right?
We're seeing a rise, I
think, of persuadability.
People have always
been persuadable.
I mean, I talk about
Abraham Lincoln in my book
and how I thought he was an
extremely persuadable leader.
So this is not a new phenomenon.
But the reality is,
in a world that's
so complex and so
hypercompetitive,
we need to be willing to adapt
and to change very quickly.
And if you think about it,
it's just a logical conclusion,
right?
The way that you adapt
and change quickly,
you need to make
a-- all new change
is preceded by a new decision.
All new decisions are preceded
by a new belief, right?
A change of mind.
So the quicker you
can change your mind,
the quicker you can adapt
to changing circumstances.
As for gender, I don't
comment a lot on gender,
at least right now, because the
research is a little bit mixed.
And you know, it's tempting.
And there is some
research to support
that, for example,
women have a tendency
to be more open-minded
and more persuadable
than men, although I haven't
really confirmed them
so I don't talk
about that that much.
But I think one part
of the research that
seems pretty unequivocal
is that diversity,
whether it be ethnic
diversity, gender diversity,
really does help.
Because, like we
talked about, one
of the ingredients
for being persuadable
is to get different
perspectives,
different opinions, to argue and
to exchange ideas with people
that disagree with you.
And people-- diversity-- that's
what diversity is, right?
It's people who come from
different walks of life,
different backgrounds, different
cultures who are trading ideas,
who have their own kind of
prism through which they
see the world.
And so to me it seems
completely logical
that diversity would
lead to better arguments,
to better exchanges, and
therefore better outcomes.
AUDIENCE: We all
have our beliefs,
and we basically do things
based on our beliefs.
What do you think about the
idea of actually doing something
against our beliefs
as an experiment?
AL PITTAMPALLI: That's
a brilliant idea.
And I kind of advocate
that all the time.
It's amazing how
the number of times,
the small number
of times, we ever
do stuff that is contrary to
our beliefs or our intuition.
I mean, what's amazing
is, the cultural meme is
trust your gut.
That's the big thing.
Everybody's trying to encourage
you to trust your gut.
We always trust our gut.
There's nothing remarkable
about trusting your gut.
We trust our gut all the time.
You trusted your gut
a million times today,
every single interaction.
It's actually way
more interesting
and way more difficult to
actually distrust your gut,
to actually make
decisions and to do things
that are contrary to your
beliefs and your preexisting
attitudes.
So one of the things you
have to be comfortable
with, and that's what
this first step to being
persuadable that I
talked about today,
is to recall your moment
of opacity, right?
The whole point
of that is to get
you to remember that this
feeling that you experience
that is produced by your
beliefs is not the truth.
You know, it feels like that's
the right direction, right?
It feels like it's the
right thing to do, right?
Like, the writing example, I
think, is salient here, right?
Like when somebody
criticizes your work,
whether it be writing
or entrepreneurship
or anything, your
gut, your belief
tells you that they're wrong.
And it's the mark, the
hallmark of responsible adults
and intelligent people
to say, wait a minute.
I'm not objective on this.
Maybe it's possible
that I'm wrong.
And it's just that
space, it's that distance
for a second, that recalling
your moment of opacity that
separates yourself from the
thought, from your belief,
from your intuition
that allows you
to make a rational decision.
It's what Daniel Kahneman
refers to as System 2, thinking,
that we all need to
become much better at.
AUDIENCE: You had this
idea to write the book,
and you had the insight and
then you wrote the book.
How were you persuaded
when you were writing it?
How did your mind change?
And how did you change
your original theory?
AL PITTAMPALLI: That's
a really great question.
I had to toss several
chapters of my book.
In fact, you know, this
book is what, 65,000 words?
I probably wrote, like,
600,000 words in total.
Because I really tried to
eat my own cooking here,
which is really tough
because I'll tell you what.
Persuadable is like
this easy thing
when you're intellectually
talking about it.
But when you have to do it
yourself, you're like, well,
this is not easy.
Because what would happen was,
I would read somebody's research
and I would say, wow,
this is fascinating.
This fits right in
with my argument.
And then I would call
them up for validation.
And you could see
yourself starting
to lead them in the
direction you want them to.
And they're resisting,
and then you're
asking these loaded
questions to get them to say
what you want them to say.
And you know, it takes a lot
of kind of effort and courage
to say, was I leading
them too much?
You know, am I wrong about this?
And you know,
luckily, I think, I
had some good editors
that helped me with this,
but I wasn't
perfectly successful.
And that's the lesson
of being persuadable.
It's not-- human beings
are very flawed this way.
Our confirmation bias
is extremely strong.
So I did my best.
And I think I did
probably better than most,
but I wouldn't say that
I'm perfect by any measure.
But I think the
lesson here is for all
of us, which is, what is
your contribution to being
persuadable?
Where in your life,
where in your work,
where in your business
can you take the time
to address the
confirmation bias,
really confront the possibility
that you may be wrong,
and then follow the evidence
wherever it may lead?
I think it's the
best thing for you.
And I also think it's the
best thing for society.
So I hope you'll
take this message
and really embrace
it and act upon it.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
It was a real pleasure
to speak with you.
[APPLAUSE]